okay yesterday was the first part of the
first 2020 Democratic presidential
debate it was very interesting some
clear winners and losers several cringe
moments which we'll talk about i live
streamed it on our youtube channel last
night we'll be live-streaming again
tonight for part two assuming that our
live-streaming privileges are not taken
away which is happening to some
youtubers who streamed yesterday's
debate not going to get into that now
but to reset Elizabeth Warren was the
only frontrunner in the first night the
other is Biden Bernie Budaj Harris all
in tonight's second part along with
Andrew yang which will be interesting
now unfortunately and not super
surprisingly a lot of questions simply
weren't answered some weren't answered
in particularly pandering ways which
I'll talk about but overall there were
some winners in this debate but it was
not a good debate in the sense that in
terms of discourse and depth it was a
disaster part of this is just the number
of candidates on stage part of this is
the format because of the number of
candidates on stage answers were one
minute and rebuttals were 30 seconds not
everybody got to answer every question
not everybody got to rebut every answer
and my impression overall is that the
three people who did the best were
Elizabeth Warren Bill DeBlasio and who
Leon Castro who I would say won the
debate in terms of substance and style
now that doesn't mean I agree with all
of their positions this is not me saying
I'm endorsing them this is simply
evaluating only their performance in
yesterday's debate of course bill de
blasio has no chance of being the
nominee and who Leon Castro has almost
no chance of being the nominee Warren
poling at about 13% heading into the
debate one because she said the right
things and she said them in the right
way period she got good questions also
that lined up with her issues and
answered the questions really well
here's one example but this comes at a
time when 71% of Americans say the
economy is doing well including 60% of
Democrats what do you say to those who
worry this kind of significant change
could be risky to the economy so I think
of it this way
who is this economy really working for
it's doing great for a thinner and
thinner slice at the top it's doing
great
four giant drug companies this is not
doing great for people who are trying to
get a prescription filled it's doing
great for people who want to invest in
private prisons just not for the
african-americans and Latin X whose
families are torn apart whose lives are
destroyed and whose communities are
ruined it's doing great for giant oil
companies that want to drill everywhere
just not for the rest of us who are
watching climate change bear down upon
us when you've got a government when
you've got an economy that does great
for those with money and isn't doing
great for everyone else that is
corruption pure and simple we need to
call it out we need to attack it head-on
and we need to make structural change in
our government in our economy and in our
country
so there's actually relatively little to
talk about with Warren in that she
overperformed compared to some past
debates she got good questions that were
in her wheelhouse just did a good job
overall and we'll see how her polling
reacts bill de blasio basically polling
cr0 the mayor of New York City has no
chance but he actually did well in this
debate because some of the people on the
stage wanted to sort of play coy with
are you in favor of this or not or
trying to have their cake and eat it too
in the sense of claiming to be
progressive without actually having to
say yes we need free college yes we need
Medicare for all and Bill DeBlasio was
aggressive in a respectful way and he
had some great moments here's just one
example of that but let me tell you what
we're hearing here already in the first
round of questions is that battle for
the heart and soul of our party I want
to make it clear this is supposed to be
the party of working people yes we're
supposed to be for 70 percent tax rate
on the wealthy yes we're supposed to be
for free college free public college for
our young people we are supposed to
break up big corporations when they're
not serving our democracy this
Democratic party has to be strong and
bold and progressive and in New York we
proven that we can do something very
different we can put money back in the
hands of working people and let me tell
you every time you talk about investing
in people and their communities you hear
folks say there's not enough money what
I say them every single time is there's
plenty of money in this world there's
plenty of money in this country it's
just in the wrong hands
come Democrats have to fix that this is
not a de Blasio endorsement it's
recognizing that he did well for the
format and for this debate even though
he's still going to be polling very
little his performance was the
second-best for me and then in third
place it was who Leon Castro he was
helped a lot by the immigration crisis
at the border because it pushed the
topic into the debate in a serious way
he genuinely knows a lot about this
issue he was able to talk about it in
depth with Cory Booker with Beto or
Roarke and appear really strong because
he is strong on this issue
let's take take a look at one clip thank
you very much plus a I'm very proud that
in April I became the first candidate to
put forward a comprehensive immigration
plan and we saw those images watching
that image of Voskhod and his daughter
Valeria is heartbreaking
it should also piss us all off if I were
president today and it ships first
action if I were president today I would
sign an executive order that would get
rid of Trump's zero-tolerance policy the
remain in Mexico policy and the metering
policy this metering policy is basically
what prompted most cotton valaria to
make that risky swim across the river
they have been playing games with people
who are coming and trying to seek asylum
at our ports of entry
Wallace cotton valetti I went to a port
of entry and then they were denied the
ability to make an asylum claim so they
got frustrated and they tried to cross
the river and they died because of that
on day one Sunday what would do that
executive order that would address
metering and then I would follow that up
in my first hundred days with
immigration reform that were onerous
Island planes that would put
undocumented immigrants as long as they
haven't committed a serious crime on a
pathway to citizenship and that would go
to the root cause of the issue which is
we need a Marshall Plan for on Gouda
in what Damara and in some bubble so
that people can find safety and
opportunity at home instead of coming to
the United States to seek it and then
later on the same issue going back and
forth with Beto or rorg who was saying a
lot but making very few points take a
look at this free dreamers forever from
any fear of deportation by making them
US citizens here in this country invest
in solutions in Central America work
with regional stakeholders so there's no
reason to make that 2,000 mile journey -
let's be very clear the reason that
they're separating these little children
from their families is that they're
using section 1325 of that act which
criminalizes coming across the border to
incarcerate the preparin and then
separate them some of us on this stage
have called to end that section to
terminate it some like congressman
O'Rourke have not and I want to
challenge all of the candidates to do
that I just think it's a mistake Beth oh
I think it's a mistake and I think that
that if you truly want to change the
system then we got to repeal that
section if not thank you then it might
as well America respond to this very
briefly in turn actually as a member of
Congress I helped to introduce
legislation that would ensure that we
don't criminalize those who are seeking
asylum and refuge in this country if
you're clean if you're fleeing the
desperation island then I want to make
sure everybody with respect I'm still
talking about everybody else you're
looking at just one small part of this
I'm talking about a comprehensive
rewrite of our immigration laws and if
we do that
not talking about our laws I'm thinking
about zillions of folks a lot of folks
that are coming are not seeking asylum
and a lot of them are undocumented
immigrants right and you said recently
that the reason you didn't want to
repeal section 1325 was because you were
concerned about human trafficking and
and drug trafficking but let me tell you
what section 18 so I got title 18 of the
u.s. code title 21 and title 22 already
covered again if immigration ended up
not being a part of yesterday's debate
Castro probably bombs and is a
non-factor but he did really well
because he's super strong on this issue
and really others knowledge of the issue
visibly paled in comparison to who Leon
Castro's Elizabeth Warren's worst moment
was on guns just sort of bumbling and
mumbling without really saying very much
and repeating that we should do research
a couple of times
tulsi gabbard had one good answer at the
end about getting out of afghanistan
otherwise not much of a factor she
really benefited from tim ryan just
saying boneheaded ly dumb things about
9/11 and foreign policy which let
Gabbard come in and make him look very
stupid on that issue and as far as the
attacks that we saw between candidates
other than who Leon Castro going after
bado
for his position on immigration almost
every attack was from bill de blasio de
Blasio went right after everyone saying
hey let's just say were for progressive
ideas if we actually claim to be
progressive de Blasio with a really
great call out of better or Roarke at
one point de Blasio talking about
immigrants didn't do this to you huge
corporations did which was a very good
moment for de Blasio de Blasio was
specific on when we should or shouldn't
intervene in other countries and the
importance of actually having authorized
War Powers for a president making those
decisions some of the disagreements were
you know Clos Bashar is lesson two free
college than Warren at least not in his
wide-ranging of a way the disagreement I
already told you about between Castro
and bado and Castro and Cory Booker on
some immigration specifics interestingly
on health care only Elizabeth Warren
and Bill DeBlasio raised their hands
when asked do you want to replace
private health care with a
government-run program this was a crazy
moment because it made no sense that of
all the people on the stage only warren
and de Blasio raised their hands in this
moment I'm going to play but it also was
a terribly asked question which should
have been called out take a look we're
gonna turn to the issue of health care
right now I really try to understand
whether may or may not be daylight
between you many people watching at home
have health insurance coverage through
their employer who here would abolish
their private health insurance in favor
of a government-run plan just to show
hands start out with so only Bill
DeBlasio and Warren put their hands up
this is a concern I mean there should be
other hands up but the question was
asked horribly the exact wording from
Lester Holt was who here would abolish
their private health insurance in favor
of a government-run plan
show of hands to start off with he
didn't say who would make private
insurance illegal he said who would
abolish their private health insurance
so he's asking who would choose to
cancel their own insurance and instead
get a government plan was the way I
understood the meaning of the question
but clearly some people on the stage
interpreted as who here wants to make
private insurance illegal which is a
terrible moment because that's a right
wing talking point that has been
spreading right I mean it did hurt some
of those who didn't put their hands up
but I wish someone had just called out
the question and said wait a second
Lester I want the government involved
and I want private insurance to be
irrelevant but I'm not talking about
making it illegal other than maybe as a
thought experiment that's a right wing
talking point meant to interfere with
serious discussions we want people not
to need private insurance it's not about
making it illegal and instead everybody
ended up answering the question sort of
as they understood it and it really was
a mess and then lastly the big losers
were john delaney bizarre answer after
bizarre answer Tim Ryan who made a fool
out of himself and beto or Roark betos
worst moment when he was asked what do
you think the top marginal tax rate
should be and he broke into incorrect
Spanish here is this is my stream in my
reaction to it in real time
some Democrats want a marginal
individual tax rate of 70% on the very
highest earners those making more than
10 million dollars a year but rates you
support that and if not what would your
top individual rate be this economy has
got to work for everyone and right now
we know that it isn't and it's gonna
take all of us coming together to make
sure that it does vamos in queer cada
persona en el éxito de este upon omean
pero si quiere Moses era so necesitamos
in qui cada persona in Westra democracia
i mean if you're gonna do it you got it
speaking spanish direction y cada vez
necesito mas escuchar right now we have
a system that favors those who can pay
for access and outcomes that's how you
explain an economy that is rigged to
corporations and to the very wealthiest
a two trillion dollar tax cut that
favored corporations while they were
sitting on record piles of cash and the
very wealthiest in this country at a
time of historic wealth inequality a new
democracy that is what because the
people no pacts no gerrymandering
automatic and same-day voter
registration bring in more voters and a
new voting rights those are many
barriers in place now that's how we each
have a voice in our democracy and make
this so he said esta economía
and he said nuestro democracia so in
Spanish words have gender so like if I
say professor if I say professor that's
a male professor if I say profesora
that's a female professor and when Beto
or work said a state economy ah he
should have said esta economy when he
said nuestro democracia he should have
said no a sterile mo class yeah but the
problem isn't speaking Spanish per se
and it's not that he's spoken correct
Spanish it was so obviously a concocted
and planned moment he's asked for the
marginal tax rate and he speaks Spanish
and I got emails from people saying
David don't tell Hispanic immigrants how
they should feel about what Beto did
maybe they liked it I'm an immigrant
from Argentina
I speak Spanish at home hearing Robert
O'Rourke struggle through incorrect
Spanish to not answer a question which I
would have loved an answer to what
should the top marginal tax rate be it's
just a turn-off and it felt like such
total pandering so a bad night for Beto
here's how I scored it so to speak I
believe Elizabeth Warren won this debate
marginally over bill de blasio number
two who Leon Castro in third place Cory
Booker with a solid showing in fourth
place
I believe Klobuchar Gabbard and Inslee
were basically tied for fifth place
neither of them really factors
I believe Tim Ryan and Delaney were tied
for eighth place doing a damage to
themselves and lastly I think Beto
O'Rourke was 10th out of ten really
doing damage to his campaign it was a
very very bad night too tonight join me
live on YouTube at 8:30 p.m. Eastern for
the live stream and commentary assuming
we are not banned from live streaming on
YouTube